[Music]
bird watching for Lake Meads Wildlife
technicians go far beyond just passing
time it's to make sure the bald eagles
that come here for the winter season are
safe and accounted for
the bald eagle an important symbol for
the United States says our national bird
the full Wing spread would be longer
than my arms can go I think they can get
up to like six feet and there are plenty
of them hanging around Lake Mead and the
bald eagles are really closely tied to
water and rivers and large Lakes
National Park Service Wildlife
technician Clayton Merrill says during
the winter months Eagles tend to come to
Lake Mead because there's plenty of food
for them the bald eagles of course are
eat a lot of uh eat a lot of fish and
dive into the water so they have a high
Overlook to look for the fish and while
they're here it's a good time to count
just how many of them there are it's
part of a national survey done every
year it's a good estimate of bald eagle
health over the entire countries this
week with the help of 41 volunteers and
binoculars in hand they spread across
the lake and counted 131 bald eagles
Merrell says in 2022 they counted 151 in
2021 there were 185 Eagles but the lower
count isn't anything to be worried about
as sometimes Eagles go somewhere else in
the winter if you come across any
Wildlife during your time here in Lake
Mead The Visitor Center wants you to
take a picture and send them in
reporting in Lake Mead Victoria Saha 8
news now I'm going to go back to bird
watching
good stuff the wildlife technicians will
hand over the information gathered at
Lake Mead to the Army Corps of Engineers
and then the data can often help with
any kind of law making decisions when it
comes to the control of lead which is
actually the major threat to those bald
eagles